i'm doing it on medicated brave woman
we'll see if i regret this
[Music]
humbling limit pushing and empowering
that's how the 31 year old model
described her all-natural unmedicated
home birth and nick was at her side the
couple documented bree's 10 and a half
hours of labor with the 11 minute
youtube video including a scary moment
bree said she noticed the baby wasn't
crying her midwife provided respiratory
support with an ear tube
[Applause]
last month bree told me nick wasn't
fully on board with the home birth idea
especially since losing his
five-month-old son zen last december i
lost my youngest son
to a brain tumor brain cancer
he's a little concerned especially you
know he has a sensitive after a loss
he's a little bit more sensitive now
so i wanted to respect that but i also
was like i'm the one birthing him so he
was like i'll support you and if
anything we go to the hospital
the healthy newborn named legendary love
weighed in at eight pounds ten ounces
how did you come up with an eight we
were actually struggling because you
know she likes to be very different so
we went back and forth for a while and i
had come up with one name and he jazzed
it up a little bit
legendary
hey
that's nick holding the little guy in
the nursery bree gave me an early tour
of the room the couple already decided
legendary love would be the name and had
this made just for him and then
legendary love yes
yes i think this just you know plays
into our relationship so
i loved that it's nick's eighth child
and two weeks ago when he co-hosted e.t
with the shell he said you can bet on
even more thirty-one-year-old abby de la
rosa is rumored to be expecting nick's
ninth child
that's why i said the stork is on the
way we'll see how it trickles down would
i be close safe to bed you would be cool
three you would be safe to bet on three
in 2022.
[Music]